look at that no chance whatsoever no  active moves for you sir yeah rook t3  and rook t1  and uh have the play yep the players  have passed move 40 which does mean that  they are getting the one second  increment  and vishy saying i can do whatever i  like  move my rook up and down the board give  a check here with a knife give a check  there  yeah no problems whatsoever  and the game's still going the game is  still going  but nothing much has changed  they're probably  inadvertently going to repeat the move  okay that's it enough  handshake and it is a draw and this  means that vishy takes away one and a  half points he is the victim in the  armageddon match  and uh anish walks away with one point  once again mishi anand  he is victorious